Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Prittlove und äh ja, ich begrüße euch zur Ausgabe Nummer hundertzwei.
UKW und ja wir müssen uns ganz kurzfristig melden, denn äh es passieren Dinge in der Ukraine und das bespreche ich heute natürlich mit Pavel. Hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Und ich bin ganz froh, dass wir uns äh letzte Woche aufgerafft haben mal alles zusammenzufassen, weil seitdem ist so viel passiert äh in diesen wenigen Tagen.
Dass das äh heut sicherlich nochmal eine ausführlichere äh Sendung werden wird, denn es geht rund in der Ukraine und äh es gibt viele, viele, viele, viele gute Nachrichten.
Und äh die wollen wir heute mal besprechen.
Ich hatte dich zwischendurch dann, als es losging, äh angeschrieben und da warst du noch gar nicht so richtig auf dem Stand der Dinge. Aufm linken Fuß erwischt.
Ja, ja, ja. Ja, ich hatte mir mal erlaubt irgendwie so einen Tag äh mal nicht auf dem Laufenden zu bleiben und kaum gucke ich mal weg irgendwie schon äh ja auf einmal geht's los da.
Genau, aber jetzt äh sind wir wieder up to date äh beide haben wir glaube ich die letzten zwei Tage im Wesentlichen 24 Stunden in der Twitter Timeline äh verbracht und auf anderen Quellen natürlich.
Um so ein bisschen Einblick zu bekommen und wahrscheinlich wird sich das Bild sogar schon während der Aufnahme dieser Sendung ändern, weil so sehr überschlagen sich die Ereignisse.
Ja, wo haben wir aufgehört letztes Mal? Also wir hatten berichtet von der Offensive der ukrainischen Armee im Gebiet Rresson.
Das ist halt der südwestliche Teil der Front.
Und diese spezielle Situation ähm in dem Gebiet, wo die Russen äh die einzige Stelle, wo die Russen ja
westlich, also rechtzeitig das vorgestoßen sind
sehr früh ja schon zu Beginn des Krieges die Stadt eingenommen haben. Ja und durch.
Mittlerweile feststellen kann die Finte der Ukraine äh dort große Truppen zusammengezogen haben.
Genaue Zahlen gibt's nicht, aber ich habe so Schätzungen gehört von.
Soldaten so in der Größenordnung und vor allem auch so ein bisschen die besseren äh Truppen, die die Russen noch aufzubieten haben.
Und das ist dann auch erstmal so weitergegangen, die ganzen Fortschritte waren überschaubar und sind es auch immer noch, aber es gibt immerhin ähm.
Graduell weitere befreite Dörfer, aber es geht eben ja langsam voran.
Widerstand ist da noch relativ groß.
Ja
So eigentlich im Süden ist alles äh so, wie wir's ungefähr erwartet haben, aber nicht eben im Osten.
Im Nordosten äh gab's dann halt jetzt diese große Überraschung.
Genau. Aber vielleicht nochmal kurz äh die Situation dort in ähm ein bisschen.
Zeichnen, also wir hatten ja äh beobachtet, dass quasi so auf der gesamten Frontlinie angegriffen wurde,
konzentriert sich das so im Wesentlichen auf drei, je nachdem wie man's sieht, äh drei oder vier Orte.
Ganz äh im Osten, ganz im Westen dieser Frontlinie und auch in der Mitte, wo so der tiefste Vorstoß bisher stattgefunden hat.
Und mittlerweile ist es so, dass die Russen sich auch teilweise zurückziehen. Also es gibt äh auch grade erste Berichte,
dass teilweise äh Russen auch schon Rückzug verhandeln und Übergabe von Waffen verhandeln. Das ist aber noch ein bisschen unbestätigt. Ähm aber es scheint wohl so zu sein, dass sie sich ein bisschen zurückziehen
vor allem.
Damit sie Stellung besetzen, wo sie sich quasi von der anderen Seite des Ufers, des Flusses mit ihrer Artillerie noch beschützen lassen können.
Dass es so ein bisschen äh die Vermutung, die da gerade äh rumgeht, ob das so genau stimmt, werden wir dann sehen. Auf jeden Fall ähm.
Hat's die Ukraine auch nicht unbedingt ähm eilig.
Und warum? Das haben wir dann eben äh gesehen. Denn nun gab es eben die mittlerweile auch weit berichtete Offensive im Nord,
Osten in äh,
Dazu vielleicht noch mal so ein bisschen, das mag vielleicht nicht jedem so klar sein, also es gibt halt die Stadt und es gibt den Oblast, das ist sozusagen.
Analog zum Bundesland, den Oblast Cresson, die meisten, nicht alle, aber die meisten äh ob Laster sind immer in irgendeiner Form nach der Hauptstadt oder der größten Stadt in dem Gebiet äh benannt.
Gebiet hier um dem gekämpft wird, äh gehört auch noch teilweise zu dem ähm Oblast-Mikolive.
Aber es macht so fast den Eindruck, dass die paar Meter, die noch zu mit gehören, mittlerweile auch schon kontestet sind, also es kann gut sein, dass auch der Oblast demnächst befreit ist.
Wiederum zieht sich aber dann eben bis nach Süden bis an die Krim heran. Und jetzt geht's.
Um Rakif und äh auch eine Raktiv ist es so, der Oblas-Krakie ist halt durch die Stadt Rakif benannt und äh die Russen hatten ungefähr na ja so ein Drittel von äh diesem Oblast äh Hakif auch mit besetzt.
Dahinter kommt dann weiter östlich äh Luhansk und alles begann mit einer ja.
Truppenverlegung der Ukraine, die ja die Russen entweder nicht.
Bemerkt haben oder wenn sie's bemerkt haben nicht mehr in der Lage waren da drauf zu reagieren oder nicht drauf reagieren.
Wollten, ja ähm es scheint einfach generell so zu sein.
Durch diese Konzentration auf eben sehr viele Truppen abgezogen sind und andere Angriffszentrum ist ja nach wie vor der Donbars.
Und seit Monaten versuchen die Russen dort die äh Städte.
Bachmut und ja wenn sie denn vorankommen würden, dann auch so die Hauptstellung der Ukraine in dem Gebiet zu erobern.
Slowjansk, das ist den aber die ganze Zeit nicht gelungen. Die Fortschritte waren da eher so im Meter bis 1hundert Meter Bereich und es ging alles sehr äh langsam, aber sie haben halt alles draufgeworfen, was sie hatten. Da haben auch diese Wagnergruppen haben dort gearbeitet.
Diese ganze Konzentration auf dieses Gebiet, insbesondere unter der Vorgabe der russischen Führung dort bis zum 15. September, das wäre so in drei Tagen. Heute haben wir den 12. September, während wir hier sprechen.
Da in irgendeiner Form Bachmut zu erobern, das ist äh ja sah eh nicht so aus als ob das funktionieren würde und jetzt können wir auch definitiv sagen, das wird nicht funktionieren.
Trotz alledem hat das eben die ganze Truppenkonzentration auf dieses Gebiet gelegt und offensichtlich.
Die Russen es dann nicht geschafft diesen Bereich, den östlichen Bereich von in irgendeiner Form nennenswert abzusichern. Also diese Tiefensicherung.
Nicht nur eine erste Frontlinie zu haben, sondern eben dahinter noch weitere Stellungen, die falls mit der ersten Frontlinie irgendwas schief läuft,
In irgendeiner Form zu unterstützen oder zumindest so eine zweite äh nahe Stellung zu haben, auf die man sich zurückziehen kann. Das hat wohl alles irgendwie nicht so richtig stattgefunden.
Begann dann mit einem Vorstoß ähm auf einen Ort, weil er äh.
Und das ging dann auf einmal sehr schnell,
Also innerhalb von einem Tag war äh die Stadt dann überrollt. Die äh Truppen, die dort die Russen stationiert hatten, die haben sich dann schnell äh zurückgezogen.
Und das hat dann eben eine interessante Dynamik ausgelöst von dort.
Wurden dann äh in Windeseile weitere ähm Ortschaften eingenommen und dann passierte eben genau das, was ich gerade angedeutet habe. Es gab halt keine zweite wirkliche Verteidigungslinie.
Das hat eben der Ukraine ermöglicht hier sehr schnell vorzustoßen.
Jetzt ist es natürlich so schnell stoßen, dass,
Sich so einfach vorstellen mit na ja kein Problem wenn die Straße frei ist dann fährt man da halt hin. Aber wenn man da eben mit Panzern und allen möglichen äh Gerät, Luftabwehr,
Truppentransportern et cetera unterwegs sein will, dann muss man das natürlich auch logistisch unterfüttern. Sprich,
nicht einfach losfahren und dann äh hält der Panzer an einer Tankstelle, weil die gibt's dann halt nicht, sondern du musst eben den ganzen Sprit mitliefern. Du musst deine Munition mitliefern und musst die äh Truppen versorgen. Du musst halt einfach alles dabei haben.
Macht eben ganz so den Eindruck, als ob die Ukrainer äh still und heimlich große Truppenkontingente aufgebaut hat, aber eben auch eine komplette Logistik in der Hinterhand hatte, um einen solchen Vorstoß,
dann auch entsprechend militärisch zu unterfüttern. Und es.
Ja und und vielleicht nur eins und es macht auch den Eindruck, als ob sie an der Stelle sowohl relativ frisches Personal eingesetzt haben, als auch.
Sehr gut ausgestattet waren mit westlichen äh Kampfsystemen. Da kamen.
Panzer zum Beispiel zum Einsatz, um irgendwie eine mobile Luftabwehr zu haben
kam dieser äh Raketen, um die Radarstation der Russen auszuschalten und es ist ihnen dann halt auch gelungen, eine relative Lufthoheit zu ähm bekommen, also da konnten dann auch die Russen
aus der Luft nicht sehr viel ausrichten.
Und äh eben was halt auch dazukommt äh noch ist, dass du es natürlich koordinieren
musst so den Vorstoß äh also um zu vermeiden, dass auch äh eigene Truppen sich gegenseitig beschießen oder deine Artillerie
irgendwo deine eigenen Truppen äh beschießt oder die aus der Luft beschossen werden oder so. Das heißt, äh ja, das erfordert schon
äh ein gewisses Maß auch an Koordination und Planung, äh wie es so schön heißt, combined
abends äh äh fair, wobei.
Was eben auch noch äh zu sehen war, dass äh so dieser Vorstoß teilweise mit sehr mobilen
Einheiten äh erstmal erfolgt ist, also mit Radfahrzeugen, teilweise mit Pick-up äh äh Trucks und äh,
Fahrzeugen, die halt schnell ähm vorrücken konnten und wo es dann eben auch zu ziemlich krassen äh ja Kontakt.
Äh gekommen.
Ist dann so, wo halt dann überraschend irgendwelche russischen Truppenreste irgendwie, die von hinten kamen äh und so, dann plötzlich mitten
in so eine ukrainische,
Kolonne reinfuhren, dann anfingen irgendwie in Panik zu verfallen gibt's so ein schönes Filmchen, dann losgerasst sind irgendwie die,
Hälfte der Soldaten irgendwie vom Panzer runtergesprungen sind, die dann drauf saßen und der das Ding dann irgendwo voll gegen einen Baum gesetzt äh hat. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das gesehen
so das war schon sehr spektakulär und äh ja.
Teilweise auch fiese Nummern, wo sich dann russische Soldaten eben ihrer äh ja Armbänder und Hoheitsabzeichen und so erledigt,
ähm entledigt haben und dann
auf ukrainische Kontrollposten zugelaufen sind und dann im letzten Moment angefangen haben irgendwie sozusagen zu zu schießen und äh und so, also da gab's auch äh paar unschöne Dinge und.
Insgesamt ist auch der Eindruck, also es war jetzt nicht so, dass die Ukrainer da jetzt nur widerstandslos rein äh rollen konnten, sondern dass.
Die Russen haben halt schon äh durchaus auch Widerstand äh geleistet so und da kam's wohl dann schon auch zu Kämpfen und sicherlich auch zu Verlusten auf ukrainischer Seite. Also es war jetzt kein Spaziergang.
Kein Spaziergang, aber es war natürlich auf jeden Fall der Überraschungseffekt, war ganz auf der Seite der Ukraine und äh was halt noch dazu kommt in diesem Gebiet,
Truppen, die dort stehen, ich glaube, das hatten wir letzte Mal auch schon mal so angedeutet, dass man eben einfach mal grundsätzlich ein bisschen unterscheiden muss.
Mit wem man's eigentlich zu tun hat, weil es gibt natürlich schon so die russische Armee, die dort natürlich den Großteil der Kräfte stellt.
Aber grade in Luhansk und eben auch in Donezk sind ja im Prinzip noch zwei andere Unterarmeen ähm aktiv, nämlich diese äh LNR und DNR, also diese.
Wofür steht das genau? Luhansk, also er hat sozusagen deren äh weitgehend aus so Kollaborateuren,
russophilen Leuten und aber dann eben auch viele mehr als Sklaven eingesetzte Einwohner dieser Gebiete die halt einfach in diese Armeen reingedrückt wurden und die,
sollten sozusagen jetzt hier die Ukraine aufhalten und.
Ja, da dann die Führer aber relativ schnell abgehauen sind und sich zurückgezogen haben,
wahrscheinlich viele auch einfach gesagt okay alles klar, wenn ihr jetzt hier nicht mehr äh wollt, dann fahre ich halt nach Hause. Ich wollte hier sowieso nicht kämpfen und äh das hat alles noch dazu beigetragen, die ohnehin äh dünne Widerstandskraft dort noch weiter auszudünnen.
Und so zwei, ich sage mal weitere Vorkommnisse äh sind mir da noch äh im Gedächtnis geblieben und haben mich beeindruckt. Ähm das eine war äh dass äh die Russen halt.
Verstärkung geschickt hatten, äh unter anderem so einen, weiß ich nicht,
einen Haufen äh mehrfach Raketenwerfer und das dann eben auch noch im russischen Fernsehen zeigten, wie jetzt sozusagen diese,
mehrfach Raketenwerfer äh jetzt dann ja die Ukraine beschießen und am nächsten Tag,
gab's äh einen äh wiederum einen Filmbericht, wo genau diese Raketenwerfer äh in ukrainische Hand gefallen waren.
Die am Tag vorher noch im russischen Fernsehen gezeigt wurden als Propaganda
haben sie zwar da irgendwie reingekriegt und haben auch irgendwie was abgeschossen, aber haben's dann nicht mehr geschafft, die da rechtzeitig wieder rauszukriegen, sodass äh ja das war halt so ein so ein so eine schöne Combo.
Fand ich ähm,
Ja äh das war das das zweite äh noch äh ja fällt mir fällt mir gleich noch ein.
Auf jeden Fall.
Der Widerstand war überschaubar und die Ukraine ist dann eben sehr schnell nach Osten vorgeschossen von Balacia aus äh leicht in den Nordosten zu,
Chefoff und äh von dort dann direkt auf,
zu und ist jetzt hier wirklich die Schlüsselstadt in diesem ganzen Ding und man kann sehr davon ausgehen, dass das eben,
primäre Ziel dieses Angriffs war. Warum? Kopiansk ist.
Ganz wichtiger Verkehrsknotenpunkt in diesem Gebiet.
Einerseits laufen da einige Straßen durch, aber was noch sehr viel wichtiger ist, dort läuft halt die Bahnlinie, genau genommen sogar zwei Bahnlinien aus Russland zusammen.
Und von dort ist das dann nach Süden die direkte Versorgungslinie für die Kämpfe in Donbass.
Und den äh Ukrainern ist es dann halt auch relativ schnell gelungen, in Kopians einzudringen.
Und sich sozusagen der Stadt zu bemächtigen. Die Stadt ist durch einen Fluss geteilt.
Ähm die äh eine der großen, wichtigen Brücken dort, also die,
gab da eine Bahnbrücke und eine eine Straßenbrücke, die Straßenbrücke war zerstört. Ich weiß nicht, ob,
Bisher schon klar ist, ob das die Russen im Rückzug gemacht haben oder ob das auch nochmal ein Angriff der Ukrainer gewesen ist, also dass die das bewusst zerstört haben. Das kann ich nicht sicher sagen.
Dazu nichts äh gesehen habe. Tatsache ist, die Stadt ist da quasi in der Mitte äh geteilt,
und alles dann sozusagen nach Osten geflohen und der ganze Westteil wurde dann eben von der Ukraine äh besetzt und da das alles so schnell ging und da sich so viele Gelegenheiten boten,
dann aber die äh Ukrainer nicht nur auf diese Stadt konzentriert, sondern im Prinzip und da geht dann halt auch noch so ein
großer äh Fluss, die selbe Strecke entlang, der Ost Kiel und an entlang dieses Ost Kiel, der halt diese Nord-Süd
Trennlinie zweier Gebiete markiert äh sind sie dann eben weiter nach Süden vorgestoßen
in den nördlichen Teil äh des Donbass und dann kriegt ihr das Ganze so richtig Fahrt denn äh,
Im Süden dieses ganzen angegriffenen Gebietes liegt halt auch eine ganz andere wichtige Stadt, nämlich Isyum und Isum
war jetzt schon seit längerer Zeit, nachdem die Russen das eingenommen haben, so ein bisschen so ein Stachel im Fleisch der Ukrainer. Dort gab's eine riesige Truppenkonzentration
Stadt ist nach Osten und nach Westen durch große Waldgebiete ähm dominiert
sich sehr gut halten und hat dann eben auch in der Stadt noch Übergänge über diesen Fluss, über den wir schon viel gesprochen haben in früheren Folgen.
Und dort haben sich eben sehr große Truppenkonzentrationen befunden. Dort lagerte sehr viel Material, sehr viel Gerät äh und es war halt einfach ein ganz äh wichtiges Zentrum und hat im
diesem Donbasskrieg äh den Ukrainern eben immer so Druck von Norden gegeben. Und jetzt kam sie eben selber aus dem Norden.
Haben dann relativ schnell, dadurch dass sie eben diese Bahnlinie in den Griff gekriegt haben, im Prinzip die gesamten Versorgungslinien und Straßen für diese Stadt.
Aufgefressen und da die Ukraine sowieso ja südlich dieser Stadt ohnehin schon immer Stellungen hatte und dort äh ist für die Russen auch nicht so richtig weiterging.
Sich also immer schneller ab, dass durch diesen schnellen Vorstoß, Ishem einfach komplett eingeschlossen werden würde und dort eben diese riesigen Truppenkonzentrationen, die dort äh vor Ort war, dass die sozusagen in eine Falle geraten ist.
Die Russen auch gemerkt und sind einfach geflohen und haben extrem viel Gerät zurückgelassen.
Und äh ja man kann sagen innerhalb einer Woche hat also die Ukraine damit zwei wichtige Städte eingenommen
und äh die Russen ganz merklich äh ja dezimiert beziehungsweise äh verdrängt und vor allem auch massiv,
Gerätschaft quasi übernommen. Also.
Zahl von Panzern und sonstigen ähm Militärvehikeln, die dort zurückgelassen wurden von Russen, die also die die Zahl ist groß und ich glaube, die sind immer noch am zählen.
Ja und ah ja, jetzt weiß ich, was der sozusagen das zweite Ding bemerkenswerte Ding äh war und zwar Berichte, die Empfang von russischer
Seite äh kamen Aufnahmen, die zwei äh der größten russischen Transporthubschrauber ähm
zeigten, die dort gelandet waren und versucht haben ähm,
dort einige der teuren und hochgeheimen elektronischen äh Kampfführungs
Geräte und Störsender und so äh äh rauszukriegen, die, weiß ich nicht, teilweise wohl kaum 30 Millionen das Stück äh äh kosten und äh wie gesagt super geheim sind. War jetzt
unklar, ob es denen gelungen
die Dinger da rauszubringen, aber bemerkenswert fand ich halt einfach, dass die Russen dann lieber irgendwie Material rausholen oder dieses wichtige Material rausholen, dass sie dafür dann äh sagen schon prioritär
äh irgendwie große Hubschrauber schicken, aber die Leute dann einfach zurücklassen, ja.
Ja und das war jetzt sozusagen das das Bild, was ich nach fünf, sechs Tagen äh,
hat und es war natürlich eine
totale Niederlage für äh die Russen. Das machte sich dann auch sehr schnell in der russischen Medienöffentlichkeit breit. Also grad diese ganzen Propaganda Diskussionssendungen, die
seit Monaten da am Poltern äh sind und irgendwie die Zerstörung von äh der Ukraine und Europa und überhaupt der ganzen Welt gefordert haben, die wundern doch auf einmal sehr kleinlaut.
Es haben sich im zunehmenden Maße auch kritische Stimmen
was für sich genommen schon mal ganz bemerkenswert ist, aber es ist auf jeden Fall so, dass das eben der Öffentlichkeit auch nicht ganz entgangen sein dürfte
die Russen sich jetzt hier für einen unfassbaren Fehler geleistet haben, beziehungsweise vielleicht ist es gar nicht so sehr ein Fehler als eben eine
Unfähigkeit gewesen, die die Ukraine entdeckt hat.
Ausgemacht hat und dann im richtigen Moment zugeschlagen hat, um diese ja schutzlose Flanke äh einzunehmen, während sich die Russen halt so ein bisschen,
ein bisschen verbohrt haben in ihrer anderen Kämpfe im auf der einen Seite und dann eben tja die wahrgenommene Hauptbedrohung ganz im Osten bei Casson.
Und äh ja jetzt äh haben sie den Salat, denn es sieht jetzt gerade nicht so aus als.
Die das jetzt noch groß äh gefixt bekommen.
Obendrauf gab's dann äh gestern noch die Ankündigung der Russen, dass sie jetzt auch noch die äh Gebiete nördlich der Stadtraktiv.
Die ganze Zeit noch besetzt hatten.
Das sind so paar Kilometer von der Grenze weg und von dort gab's auch immer wieder Artilleriebeschuss et cetera. Das äh diese Gebiete jetzt aufgegeben werden,
quasi die Russen mehr oder weniger komplett aus äh Rakiev äh zurückgezogen haben, beziehungsweise dort.
Verdrängt worden. Es fehlen jetzt noch so ein paar Meter nach äh Osten, die auf der anderen Seite dieses Oskiflusses sind. Aber es gibt auch schon Berichte, dass es auch dort ähm.
Bald weitergehen könnte.
Ja und an einigen Stellen sind sie ja quasi bis an die russische Grenze schon vorgestoßen so
Und äh fanden dort auch nur Grenzposten vor. Also wenn sie gewollt hätten
Sie auch weiter nach Russland reinmarschieren können, weil auf der anderen Seite war halt auch nix und mich dann jetzt natürlich auch gefragt,
Ähm gut, die Russen ähm.
Können sich jetzt über die Grenze zurückziehen und die Frage ist, können Sie sich da in Ruhe quasi hinter der Grenze jetzt erst mal wieder neu gruppieren oder äh wie weit
wird halt jetzt dann die Ukraine auch ähm ich sage mal nach Russland äh hineinwirken oder vielleicht. Ich meine, würde sich ja dann auch äh anbieten äh zum Beispiel dann keine Ahnung Pilgerort.
Oder so anzugreifen und äh ja
oder dort die Infrastruktur halt zu zerstören, weil und ich denke, dass es jetzt ist dann auch nicht so unwahrscheinlich, wäre jetzt nicht der erste äh sagen Angriff.
Auf äh russisches äh Territorium und wenn die da Truppen konzentrieren äh so, denke ich, ist das auch ein legitimes Ziel und ich glaube nicht, dass die,
Ukraine jetzt war sie die russische Grenze jetzt als als irgendwie heilig äh betrachten wird.
Heilig, sicherlich nicht, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich wäre schon sehr überrascht. Also äh das Ganze würde sie ja dann auch politisch in die Bedrängnis äh bringen, ne, weil das dann natürlich sozusagen Aggressionen gegenüber Russland und äh so
also sie haben sehr viel mehr davon zu gewinnen, dass sie jetzt einfach ihre Dörfer befreien, dass sie da äh glückliche Menschen zeigen
in irgendeiner Form Stellung einnehmen, um diese Grenze auch abzusichern, weil in dem Moment, wo sie nach Russland vordringen
wäre das für Sie ja dann, ich meine, was wollen Sie, was wollen Sie da? Ja, also wenn Sie Infrastruktur zerstören wollen,
tun sie ja schon die ganze Zeit durch äh Drohnenangriffe äh Raketeneinsätze. Das ist ja sehr viel effizienter. Dann müssten sie ja selber noch äh Dörfer überlaufen und hätten dann letzten Endes genau das gleiche Problem wie die Russen in der Ukraine auch, also den Schuh.
Mit Sicherheit nicht anziehen.
Mehr äh ich sage mal, äh ich glaube der der gut der Grund ist, dass natürlich Priorität hat erstmal seinen eigenes Territorium.
Ähm so zu befreien und wieder unter Kontrolle äh zu äh bekommen. Das, denke ich, ist sozusagen der der Haupt,
äh Punkt, aber ich würde das halt tatsächlich auch nicht hundertprozentig äh äh
schließen äh äh so was, auch um zum vielleicht, weiß ich nicht, ob an der Stelle äh oder so, aber auch um dann äh natürlich eventuell Druck von anderen Stellen zu nehmen, weil dann natürlich die Russen halt völlig
äh äh erstmal äh ja Panik schieben müssten oder dann ihre Prioritäten verlagern müssten. Deswegen kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass es zu irgendeinem Zeitpunkt
ähm,
auch noch passiert, zumal die Russen halt sich gar nicht drauf eingestellt haben. Die haben da nix. Ja, da ist auch irgendwie nix in in Grenznähe so richtig.
Gut, ich meine, du redest jetzt von der von der Nordflanke. Da ist halt Belgorot. Und Belgorot ist eben die Stadt, aus der der ganze Krieg die ganze Zeit versorgt wurde.
Das ist ihr äh primäres Einfallstor gewesen. Das heißt, da sind dann auch entsprechende Waffenbestände et cetera. Also das würde dann, glaube ich, den Russen überhaupt nicht äh schwer fallen auf eigenem Gebiet zuzuschlagen. Also,
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, äh weder dass das in irgendeiner Form politisch klug wäre, noch militärisch äh viel bringen würde
die eigentlichen Ziele der Ukraine sind ja auch klar, sie wollen jetzt vor allem erstmal ihre eigenen Gebiete befreien und haben ja dann auch die Verpflichtung, ihren eigenen Bürgern gegenüber äh hier das Maximalmögliche zu tun.
Derzeit sieht es eh so aus, dass sie ihre Kräfte, die sie jetzt zusammengezogen haben und die ganzen Waffen, dass sie die jetzt eben primär dafür verwenden, die Russen aus ihrem eigenen Territorium zu vertreiben.
Man wird sehen.
Was jetzt als nächstes passiert. Das Ganze ist ja dann auch noch von,
weiteren kleinen offensiven
auch begleitet worden
unter anderem haben sie parallel zu ihrem Angriff auf Isum auch noch ein paar Kilometer weiter im Westen. Die strategisch auch nicht ganz unwichtige Stadt Lyman angegriffen,
Ist die Situation derzeit noch ein bisschen unklar, aber es macht so den Eindruck, als ob sie hier die Stadt weitgehend auch schon eingenommen haben, derzeit aber noch damit beschäftigt
sind, die zu clearen, also wenn man halt in so eine Stadt reingeht, dann wird's natürlich auch sicher sein, dass da nicht irgendwelche,
Truppen noch irgendwo lagern, beziehungsweise möchtest du natürlich dann auch schauen, okay, wie sieht's denn hier überhaupt aus, was ist denn hier unter Umständen noch an Munition und Gerät zu?
Holen. Damit werden Sie jetzt wahrscheinlich in diesem Gebiet auch eine Weile beschäftigt sein und dann denke ich, sind Sie vor allem damit äh beschäftigt ihre
defensiver aufzubauen, also äh ich habe ja schon diesen Fluss erwähnt, diesen Ost Kielfluss, der da eben von Norden
nach Süden bis zum Donbass äh fließt um dort dann in diesen äh Fluss ähm zu münden.
Und das ist zwar kein besonders tiefer Fluss.
Es ist schon ein großes Gewässer aber in dieser Jahreszeit eher seicht. Also man kann da wohl auch,
mehr oder weniger easy durchfahren ist schon nochmal so eine Begrenzung, wo du jetzt nicht einfach durchpowern kannst und vielleicht auch nicht überall problemlos,
stoßen kannst, aber es ist eben jetzt auch nicht so, dass das jetzt wieder,
so was weiß ich, mehrere Kilometer breit wäre oder so etwas und unheimlich,
ne, das ist eher so ein Feuchtgebiet.
Derzeit zumindest und äh ist jetzt für die Ukraine.
Erstmal so eine gute Verteidigungslinie, die sie,
jetzt sichern müssen, wo sie mit der Logistik nachziehen müssen, wo sie jetzt quasi auch alles dahin bringen müssen, um von dort auch äh weiter vorstoßen zu können,
tun sie sicherlich derzeit auch schon. Abgesehen davon, dass es auch schon Gerüchte gibt, dass sie eben auch schon weiter nach Osten vorgedrungen sind,
und es vor allem auch viele Berichte gibt, dass die nächsten Städte, die jetzt im Prinzip in ihre Reichweite gelangen, vor den Russen auch teilweise schon verlassen wurden. Also das ist gerade noch so ein bisschen unklar. Ich schätze mal, da wissen wir in einer Woche sehr viel mehr drüber.
Allerdings hat sich jetzt eben durch diesen,
Angriff die gesamte das gesamte Vorzeichen des Krieges irgendwie gedreht. Hatten wir also.
Vor einer Woche äh im Prinzip noch die Situation, dass die Russen mehr oder weniger übermächtig erschienen und überall den Ukrainern einheizten, sieht's jetzt einfach mal komplett
anders aus, erstens weil sie ihm diese Gebiete zurückgewonnen haben, einen hohen,
hochmotivierenden äh Faktor hier sozusagen mit reingebracht haben, einen echten Sieg innerhalb von einer Woche,
knapp 9.000 Quadratkilometer Land zurückgewonnen haben, also deutlich mehr als die Russen in den vier Monaten vorher sich äh erkämpft haben.
Und vor allem die erwähnte Bahnlinie.
Die sie durch die Einnahme von unter ihre Kontrolle gebracht haben, schneidet,
russische Stadt Belgort komplett von dem Kriegsgeschehen im der Ukraine.
Es gibt erstaunlich wenig Bahnlinien in diesem Gebiet.
Es gibt dann nur noch eine zweite, die auch so von Norden nach Süden läuft, wo die Russen theoretisch noch etwas.
Führen äh können, aber die führt eben auch nicht direkt in den Donbass.
Und äh das führt durch die Stadt äh Staro Billsk auch da gibt's wohl schon Fluchtbewegungen, aber.
Das Kappen dieser Versorgungsleitung fehlt den Russen jetzt einfach die Möglichkeit aus Russland dort ordentlich Gerät reinzubringen.
Zwar noch eine Strecke im Süden von der Stadt Rostock aus
führt dann so nach äh Donuts, aber diese Gebiete, über die wir jetzt die ganze Zeit gesprochen haben, insbesondere der Norden von Luhansk.
Die stehen relativ blank da und diese eine Bahnstrecke, die zwar die Ukraine jetzt noch nicht eingenommen hat, ist nach einem,
kleineren, weiteren Vorstoß problemlos auch durch diese Haymaß äh Raketen angreifbar und es gibt da so zwei Brücken, wenn sie die zerstören, dann ist halt auch diese Verbindung dahin.
Also das sieht überhaupt nicht gut aus und ich äh also für die Russen, ich,
wäre nicht überrascht, wenn wir bald einen zweiten Vorstoß sehen würden
äh die Ukraine quasi in den Norden von Luhansk einfällt, weil dort einfach die Gegenwehr nicht da ist. Die Russen können nicht verstärken. Die haben nix mehr zum Verstärken. Wir haben.
Ihre wichtigste Versorgungslinie oder die Russen machen alles mit der mit der Bahn, mit.
Mit Transportern können sie das niemals äh leisten. Dafür sind diese Strecken zu groß,
Transporter viel zu anfällig die haben auch einfach nicht den Durchsatz äh
den du brauchst, schon gar nicht große Raketensysteme und so weiter,
nennenswerter Zahl da ins Land zu bringen. Deswegen
leben die jetzt sozusagen von ihren Vorräten und diese Vorräte,
nun auch schon seit Wochen von den Ukrainern mit den Heimatsystemen äh attackiert und eine.
Munitionslager nach dem anderen äh geht den Rauch auf. Deswegen
kann es sehr gut sein, dass sie jetzt hier über diesen Vorstoß noch einen zweiten noch sehr viel weiterreichenden Vorstoß bis in Luhansk rein äh vornehmen können und damit die Russen noch weiter von Norden,
unter Druck setzen können.
Eigentlich überraschende äh äh war, dass halt die Ukrainer in der Lage äh waren irgendwie äh so viele Reserven,
aufzubauen. Ähm und äh dann dann dort auch äh unbemerkt äh zu massieren und die große Frage ist jetzt und da gibt es eben auch.
Berechnungen von Leuten,
die ich jetzt nicht wirklich in der Lage bin nachzuvollziehen, die meinten, es könnte sein, dass sozusagen das nicht die einzige Truppenansammlung.
Ist, ähm sozusagen an neu ausgehobenen oder äh ja in Reserve gehaltenen Truppen, sondern dass es irgendwo noch eben eine zweite äh größere Reserve äh gibt, die an anderer Stelle eben nochmal,
losschlagen äh äh könnte.
Ja aber das ist halt ja ihr.
Spekulation, aber natürlich jetzt auch nicht nicht ausgeschlossen und äh,
muss natürlich immer vorsichtig äh sein, dass man in seinen Erwartungen auch nicht äh irgendwie drüber.
Schießt so, weil ähm ja.
Aber wir haben alle Faktoren, die jetzt hier zum Tragen kamen.
In irgendeiner Form hier auch schon mal erwogen. Also die niedrige Motivation der russischen Truppen.
Die Abnutzung der Russen durch die massiven Vorstöße, die sie gemacht haben. Die haben dermaßen viel Artillerie eingesetzt, haben dermaßen viele Leute äh.
Verloren, ja. Die Schätzungen gehen auf fünfzigtausend,
Soldaten auf russischer Seite, die mindestens umgekommen sind und das sind nicht nur die offiziellen Zahlen, die die Ukraine meldet, sondern das sind auch Zahlen, die sich so ein bisschen aus den äh Ausgleichszahlungen des russischen Finanzministeriums äh
ausrechnen lassen.
Ja, da ist, ich meine, dieses Dokument, was da aufgetaucht ist.
Konnte jetzt die Echtheit noch nicht wirklich verifizieren äh so vor mit äh aber wenn das stimmen sollte, dass in der Größenordnung von irgendwie weiß nicht
48.000 Hinterbliebenen, oder Zahlungen oder so äh äh zu erwarten,
sind äh jetzt dann und das dafür Geld zurückgestellt werden soll, würde das bedeuten, dass die äh.
Verluste auf russischer Seite, wenn man jetzt LPR und DNR und.
Äh Wagner und äh äh Syrer und weiß der Geier, wen noch alles,
einen ja gehören ja da irgendwie.
Mehr so eine Showtruppe, ne.
Und die kriegen wahrscheinlich auch äh äh also ich denke mal, die würden halt auch,
kriegen aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass halt
sozusagen das russische Finanzministerium die ja
sozusagen denen auch mit entsprechenden Renten unter die Arme greift, weil die haben ja mit der russischen Armee nichts zu tun und.
Ähm wenn man äh davon ausgeht jetzt, dass sie dort auch wegen ja allgemeiner Mobilmachung.
Bis zu 250.000 sagen ja Männer äh irgendwie
in äh Luhansk und ausgehoben haben könnten, die dann auch einen sehr großen Teil der Verluste, deswegen gehen wir davon aus, dass so ungefähr
60 bis 70 Prozent irgendwo in der Größenordnung der gemeldeten äh äh Opfer eben aus Luhansk und im Grunde genommen eigentlich Ukrainer
die sagen von Ukrainern umgebracht wurden, auch so eine alte Taktik so, man schickt halt dort die Leute, die da wohnen
in den Krieg, die bringen sich dann sozusagen gegenseitig um und dann wird eben auch diese Gegend entvölkert und dann kann man dort zuverlässige Russen ansiedeln. Also das ist jetzt nicht nur sagen wir mal, das ist durchaus auch mit
beabsichtigt, äh sagen dort äh oder spielt keine Rolle dann dort viele von diesen oder Luhanskern äh äh,
ja zu zu verlieren, sodass.
Wenn also wenn diese Zahl von 50.000 stimmt.
Äh oder 48.000 Russen kann man davon ausgehen, dass wahrscheinlich.
Jahrhundert bis 150tausend
Soldaten
die für Russland kämpfen, getötet äh äh worden äh sind,
dass tatsächlich die Russen äh wie gesagt nicht nicht nur irgendwie ihre zweihunderttausend,
eigenen Truppen, die sie da versammelt hatten, sondern nochmal weitere 200 bis 400000 aus Luhansk und und äh Waffen hatten. Das heißt, dass da in Wirklichkeit
stimmt wahrscheinlich.
Vielmehr Soldaten noch auf russischer Seite gekämpft haben und eben ums Leben gekommen sind, zählt man dann noch die Verwundeten.
Äh äh dazu und die die äh ja sich ergeben haben oder in Kriegsgefangenschaft geraten sind, dann
äh äh kommt man potenziell, weiß ich nicht, auf
ja hunderttausende an Soldaten, die die Russland auf die eine oder andere Art verloren hat, nicht mehr zum Kämpfen zur Verfügung stehen plus,
dass ja jetzt hier so die sechs Monatsmarke erreicht haben und viele derer, die sich jetzt so vertraglich verpflichtet haben, haben sich halt für sechs Monate verpflichtet, ja
Haben deswegen auch jetzt eigentlich keinen Bock mehr äh da länger zu äh
bleiben und das spielt glaube ich auch noch mit eine Rolle, dass das jetzt schon so lange dauert und insofern hast du Recht.
Aber ähm ja wie wie wie großflächig und und wie,
äh jetzt äh der Zusammenbruch äh der russischen.
Streitkräfte geht,
40, 40 zeigen. Aber gibt ja noch andere Zeichen,
Zeichen. Jetzt zum Beispiel die nordkoreanischen Waffenlieferungen.
Ähm über die wir, weiß nicht, ob wir beim letzten Mal schon drüber.
Geredet hatten, aber ähm,
Ja, da gab's äh Halt äh mhm okay. Erst mal sagen Spekulationen, okay ist das jetzt ein Zeichen dafür, dass den Russen jetzt die Munition ausgeht, weil wie gesagt, eigentlich sollte Munition so ziemlich das Letzte sein, was den Russen ausgeht, also an sich nach allen
Berechnungen äh im im Westen müsste Russland eigentlich noch für mindestens zwei Jahre Krieg
Munition haben, deswegen äh so.
War jetzt dann auch die Frage, okay, machen die das jetzt einfach nur, weil sie plötzlich langfristig vorausplanen?
Die Russen so und sich auf ein, zwei Jahre Krieg oder so vorbereiten
oder was steckt jetzt dahinter oder weiß ich nicht, wollen sie jetzt ihr überschüssiges
Öl an Nordkorea loswerden und die haben aber sonst nix zum Bezahlen und dann nehmen sie halt Munition plus dass sie sich bei der Munition auch,
Möglicherweise, um Munition handelt, die Nordkorea mal von Russland gekauft hat.
Jetzt da 20 Jahre gelagert haben oder 30 Jahre und jetzt möglicherweise dann wieder mit ein bisschen Aufschlag äh
an die Russen zurückverkauft äh äh werden.
Und ähm ja äh man ist jetzt nicht ausgeschlossen, dass die Russen plötzlich.
Hier äh langfristig anfangen zu planen, aber wenn man sich
den Rest des Chaos anguckt, ist es halt auch ein bisschen unklar und,
Was jetzt natürlich nach dem Vorstoß ähm auch im äh Netz,
hochkam, war so ein so ein Tweet, den ich mal übersetzt habe und ein bisschen angepasst. So, ja,
wär's nicht höchste Zeit für einen Aufruf der intellektuellen an Nordkorea und Iran.
Waffenlieferungen an Russland einzustellen und an Moskau zu appellieren, einen Frieden nach Bedingungen aus Kiew zu,
Tieren, weil meine diese Kriegsprofiteure aus Nordkorea und Iran wollen den Krieg nur verlängern und die USA in einem Stellvertreterkrieg bis zum letzten Russen bekämpfen, ja.
So ähm ja.
Okay, Zynismus.
Feld noch mal kurz auf diese Situation in der äh Gänze.
Wir hatten ja auch schon vorher darüber gerätselt, okay wie war denn jetzt bitte die Ukraine überhaupt in der Lage, diesen Moment so zu nutzen?
Und äh in inwiefern war das sozusagen Zufall und inwiefern war das geplant?
Ich denke, es zeigen schon viele Hinweise drauf, dass sie.
Also erstmal, sie hatten die Truppen dort bewaffnet, sie hatten sie vor Ort, sie haben die Logistik aufgebaut.
Waren für diesen Vorstoß vorbereitet und sie haben ihn auch von langer Hand geplant. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob sie.
Ein festes Datum hatten in dem Sinne.
Sondern sie haben in irgendeiner Form wahrscheinlich auch viele Signale äh gewartet, aber sie müssen auch ganz gute Intelligenz gehabt haben darüber, wie es denn nun in diesem Gebiet eben mit den äh russischen Stellungen auch wirklich aussieht.
Und ähm da mag sicherlich ein gewisser Opportunismus äh auch eine Rolle gespielt haben, insofern dass sie eben den konkreten Zeitpunkt sehr kurzfristig erst bestimmt haben.
Aber Sie waren eben darauf vorbereitet und ähm ja ist, dass sie äh es überhaupt jetzt in der Zwischenzeit neben den ganzen Kämpfen geschafft haben.
Zwei oder sogar drei größere äh Truppenkontingente komplett neu aufzubauen und im Prinzip in Stellung zu bringen.
Ja ich meine ja äh ich meine eine Variante wäre unwahrscheinlich wäre das den Russen am liebsten oder vielleicht wären sie sozusagen diese äh dieses Narrativ äh äh möglicherweise dann auch,
pushen irgendwann, nämlich ja, dass die Ukraine mit Unterstützung weltbester Militärexperten und
künstlicher Intelligenz gestützter Schlachtplanung, gestützt auf Geodaten irgendwie und Drohnen und Satellitenaufklärung, Millionen von Schlachtsimulationen gefahren und den perfekten Plan berechnet haben, ja, sodass die Russen halt einfach
keine Schnitte hatten. So oder ich mein ja sozusagen das andere Extrem der Wahrheit äh äh oder,
wäre ja okay, wir haben halt alles, was sie hatten irgendwie an einer günstigen Stelle konzentriert und halt
losgeschickt so nachdem sie dann eben vorher mit der Offensive Russland dazu gebracht hatten die Positionen auszudünnen und ich denke ja die Wahrheit äh sagen wird.
Wahrscheinlich irgendwo die sein, dass sie halt.
Geguckt haben, was machen die Russen so und gesehen haben, oh, die ziehen irgendwie diese Truppen.
Und diese Truppen ab und diese Truppen ab.
Die meinen's jetzt wohl ernst und haben dann irgendwann gesehen, okay äh die haben da jetzt so wenig
bietet sich dann jetzt doch die Gelegenheit, aber ich denke, dass es doch äh irgendwie mehrere Wochen an an
Planung oder dass das zumindest diese Option oder dieser Plan in der Schublade lag.
Plus vielleicht haben Sie auch einfach auf historische Planungen der Wehrmacht zurückgegriffen, weil.
Die hat nämlich in der neunzehnhundertzweiundvierzig
in äh der Schlacht bei Carshon im Prinzip fast dasselbe äh äh gemacht. Also wenn man sich sagen dort anguckt.
Wie damals die Wehrmacht und das war die letzte erfolgreiche, auch Kesselschlacht, die die Wehrmacht geführt hat und äh ja äh dort eben auch innerhalb von drei Tagen,
bisschen südlicher als die Ukraine jetzt, aber grundsätzlich genau so vorgerückt ist, also wenn man sich das anguckt, ist schon gespenstisch äh wie ähnlich. Sozusagen
äh vor, ja was ist das jetzt vor 80 Jahren ähm.
Dort äh die die äh Kämpfe abgelaufen sind. Hoffen wir nur, dass es dann nicht so wie vor 80 Jahren dann dann weitergeht. Das äh wäre jetzt ein bisschen blöd.
Aber hm ja ähm gesagt das war schon ziemlich.
Abgefahren und äh ja.
Involvierte sicherlich auch ein erhebliches Maß an an Planung und,
Vorbereitung. Also das war jetzt nicht nur rein opportunistisch.
Sagtest, sondern ein Plan und irgendwann hat man dann,
gesagt, okay äh die Bedingungen sind dafür gegeben und,
äh denke ich, hat das Go gegeben.
Und dann ist es halt einfach äh zumindest hörte man äh dass es halt besser gelaufen ist äh ja als äh sie selbst erwartet hatten.
Vor allem ist es halt der totale mentale äh Zusammenbruch. Also ich denke äh das Ganze kann schon jetzt äh etwas in
Gang bringen, was so für die Russen überhaupt nicht mehr reversibel ist. Also wie wollen sie jetzt sozusagen hier überhaupt noch in eine Position der Stärke reinkommen. In,
sie keinen Meter mehr vorrücken können und im auch nicht.
Wären Sie dazu in der Lage gewesen, dann hätten Sie das in den letzten Monaten schon in irgendeiner Form erzielt, aber tatsächlich stecken Sie da einfach äh fest. Und ähm jetzt, wo die ganzen Versorgungslinien,
Norden abgeschnitten sind, wird einfach äh zumindest dieses nördliche Donbass Kriegsschauplatzgebiet ähm,
mittelfristig fallen. Es gibt jetzt schon äh Berichte, dass die Ukrainer auch wieder auf die jüngst erst verlorenen Städte Lucid Chansk und äh vorstoßen,
Lyman hatte ich ja schon äh erwähnt, dass schwächt also auch das ganze Konzept einer Einkesselung der Russen, also der äh Einkesselung der Ukrainer in diesem Gebiet. Äh durch diese Umschließung, also nachhaltig, dadurch dass halt
und eben vor allem weggefallen ist, ist die ganze Nordfront da im im Donbass, ist halt einfach äh weg und in dieser Ostfront
immer noch irgendwie versuchen vorwärts zu kommen, sind die Fortschritte einfach so marginal.
Das äh jetzt eben durch das Ausbleiben der Versorgung,
diese Bahnstrecke, die jetzt die Ukraine äh im Griff hat, es einfach nicht absehbar ist, wie sie hier noch in irgendeiner Form
vorwärtskommen wollen. Dazu äh gibt's eben.
Eine Vielzahl von weiteren,
äh Ukraine haben auch einen Angriff auf den,
Flughafen in Dunetzk zum Beispiel gemacht. Da verläuft ja seit seit Jahren die Frontlinie so direkt vor dieser Großstadt. Das ist ja äh völlig absurd, ja? Also das diese zwar diese Stadt eingenommen haben, aber um diese Stadt herum einfach ähm
Russen niemals so richtig vorangekommen sind und äh gerade auf dieser Frontlinie dort liegt eben genau dieser Flughafen
denen jetzt äh die Ukrainer nochmal angegriffen haben. Also es gibt viele, viele, viele kleine Nadelstiche und vor allem und das muss man jetzt einfach mal als.
Gesamtsituation festhalten. Die Initiative liegt jetzt wieder bei der Ukraine. Die Russen,
reagieren auf das, was die Ukraine macht und nicht die Ukraine reagiert,
auf das, was die Russen machen. Und sie haben jetzt in gewonnen, sie werden in äh Fortschritte erzielen, haben dort auch noch Zeit, ein, zwei Monate, bis dann äh die Russen dort einfach komplett ausgeblutet sind, weil sie auch an keine
herankommen und dann äh ist da nicht mehr viel zu holen.
Dazu gibt's jetzt noch äh Gerüchte über eine mögliche dritte Offensive.
Da bin ich mir jetzt noch nicht so sicher, inwiefern das jetzt wieder nur so eine Finte ist.
Ja aber äh wenn man sich das so geografisch mal anschaut, man hat also jetzt diesen
riesigen, südlichen Bereich, ich nehme jetzt mal diesen Luhansk,
äh raus, der ja jetzt schon um diesen Bereich
verkleinert wurde. Ich denke, dass nur Hansk einfach relativ schnell von den Ukrainern zurückerobert werden wird,
es spielt sich eigentlich alles in diesem Südstreifen der Ukrainer ab,
zum äh am äh Asowschen Meer entlang, also da wo auch äh
äh liegt die Stadt, die so dramatisch nähergebombt wurde und sollte es jetzt den Ukrainern in irgendeiner Form.
Gelingen in dieser Südfront äh an irgendeiner Stelle vorzustoßen. Es gibt da Gerüchte, es gibt so einen Ort Wude da, wo sie äh
angeblich Präsenz haben, aber es erscheint mir noch nicht bestätigt und äh an der im westlichen Teil von dieser Linie äh Saporischa,
wo auch ähm auf der anderen Seite des äh,
dieses Atomkraftwerk liegt äh bei dar, was wir schon äh erwähnt haben, wo es so viel Tank äh drum gibt und was mittlerweile abgeschaltet ist. Also wenn sie in irgendeiner Form hier
auch noch die ähm Versorgungslinien unterbrechen können, dann wird's halt richtig bitter, weil dann müssen sich einfach äh die Russen.
Irgendwann ja, ich weiß nicht, also ich sehe einfach, ich habe sehe da einfach keine Perspektive mehr, wie sie das noch drehen wollen.
Ja? Ich meine, gut, langfristig, ich sage mal, ist Russland dann immer noch ein großes Land und ich sage mal, im über sage mal sechs, zwölf, 18 Monate oder so
werden die sicherlich in der Lage sich auch wieder zu regenerieren
sage ich mal, es sei denn jetzt äh in der Zeit schlägt dann auch nochmal äh äh so richtig äh die Sanktionen zu ähm aber grundsätzlich sagen wir mal.
Nicht sagen hat, hätte Russland jetzt mittel und langfristig,
durchaus die Chance wieder zurückzukommen so,
Aber äh nicht einfach so und hm.
Ein anderer Aspekt ist ja normalerweise denken, naja gut.
Wenn ich jetzt in die Offensive gehe, ist jetzt die normale, dann, dann, dann verausgabe ich mich, habe natürlich,
hohe Verluste, weil ich irgendwie in der Offensive man eigentlich immer mehr Leute verliert und mehr Material als bei der Verteidigung und dann selbst wenn ich erfolgreich bin so,
und vorgerückt bin, muss ich dann erstmal konsolidieren und meine Versorgungslinien werden länger und meine Truppen sind geschwächt und müssen jetzt erstmal ruhen und
äh ja und in der Zeit,
dann sozusagen wieder auch verwundbar für einen Gegenangriff unter Umständen, wenn der Gegner dann frische Truppen oder Reserven äh äh ran bringt.
In dem Fall scheint es aber so zu sein, dass die Ukrainer durch diesen.
Vorstoß oder in dieser Offensive jetzt nicht allzu sehr geschwächt worden äh sind und äh sogar noch äh es geschafft haben,
Ja
jede Menge Panzer und Waffen und vielleicht auch äh Material zu kriegen, die sie teilweise ja sofort fertig gemacht hatten und äh insofern,
so äh steht tatsächlich dem möglicherweise nichts im Wege des die Ukrainer tatsächlich dann äh ja
noch weiter vormarschieren oder noch äh äh ja oder keine allzu lange Pause brauchen. Äh sie müssen die ganzen erbeuteten russischen Panzer wie gesagt umpinseln einmal irgendwie durch die Wartung
äh schenken äh dann die russischen Panzer äh ja aus zwei mach einen und dann äh ja,
wieder losschicken und es sah auch so aus, als hätten die Ukrainer jetzt ein bisschen Routine auch entwickelt, ich sage mal im Wiedererobern von Städten.
Also es scheint auch so planmäßig dann abzulaufen so. Wie gesagt, erst zu den Security äh
und äh dann ja irgendwann das offiziell verkünden und Flagge hissen und dann gleich aber auch so sich die Ermittler und
Anwälte im äh äh Gepäck so zur Beweissicherung und äh also das äh ja scheint halt
schon auch bisschen ja koordinierte Rückeroberung äh zu sein, was sie da betreiben.
Genau, inklusive des Wiederaufbaus der der Infrastruktur, ne, also die äh meisten Städter sind ja unter Umständen von von äh Stromnetz und Wasserversorgung und so weiter äh vielleicht abgeschnitten.
Je nachdem wo man äh hinschaut und dass es natürlich dann eben auch.
Das erste was passiert das hat man ja dann in Kiew gesehen, also die ganze Umgebung von Kiew wurde dann halt schnell.
Ja freigeräumt von übrig gebliebenen äh Gerät und viele Freiwillige haben sich dort äh engagiert, um den Leuten dabei zu helfen, ihre Häuser wieder aufzubauen et cetera. Im einzelnen.
Einblick wie wie umfangreich das jetzt schon erfolgt ist, aber es findet statt diese Gesellschaft funktioniert und es sind ja auch äh,
Leute und sind ja nicht alle geflohen, also ist wirklich ähm viel. Es ist auch natürlich auch damit zu rechnen, dass jetzt äh weitere Geflüchtete auch wieder in die Ukraine zurückkehren werden.
Gerade die befreiten Gebiete oder eben auch jetzt überhaupt in die Region äh Rakif.
Mhm. Na, ich bin gespannt.
Ja gut, das werden wir werden wir sehen. Also mein mein Tipp ist äh als nächstes kommt der Norden äh von Luhansk und dann noch einen Angriff im Süden und dann äh.
Ganz schwierig.
Ja das der der andere Punkt ist ja auch das weite Teile jetzt irgendwie von da äh von Donezg und äh Luhansk ja
von den Russen quasi evakuiert oder entvölkert worden sind, da leben halt auch kaum noch normale Leute an an in in vielen Gegenden so. Die sind halt alle nach äh ja nach Russland.
Äh rüber oder nicht alle, aber aber viele eben oder zumindest äh alle Russen, ja und,
Auf jeden Fall äh ja wurde gemunkelt, dass äh wie gesagt, die Russland äh nach wie vor äh größter Waffenlieferant für die Ukraine ist.
Ja, das kann man auf jeden Fall mal äh festhalten. Ja und es sieht halt nicht gut aus, um die Motivation und ich denke, die Zeit spielt jetzt mittlerweile äh noch mehr als bisher für die Ukraine. Die haben halt äh einfach jetzt die Oberhand.
Zumindest mittelfristig jetzt erstmal und langfristig wird man sehen wie es hängt natürlich alles davon ab äh wie Russland jetzt reagiert. Aber eine ja oder eine Sache noch äh so.
Ähm ja äh mit dem General hattest du das mitbekommen eigentlich.
Ja, also es gab äh eine Gefangennahme eines Generals. Getötet wurden innerhalb dieses Krieges ja gerade zu Beginn einige.
Was ja an sich schon mal äh eine eine Besonderheit war, weil normalerweise in Kriegengenerale Generelle nicht fallen und schon gar nicht.
Gefangen genommen werden, aber das ist ja offensichtlich äh geschehen im Rahmen dieser Offensive.
Ja, es gibt es ist noch nicht äh äh sozusagen von offizieller Seite wurde noch nichts bestätigt, weder äh die Russen haben's weder bestritten
und den Mann irgendwie präsentiert äh noch haben jetzt die äh Ukrainer von offizieller Seite
das Ganze bekannt gegeben, aber hm was es halt gab, äh war eben ein Bild von einem Kriegsgefangenen,
den äh angeblichen in der Uniform eines russischen Oberstleutnants, der
aber eben frappierende Ähnlichkeit mit Andrej Sitschewoi hatte, der.
Der der kommandierende General der Westgruppe der russischen Streitkräfte ist, also quasi.
Einer von also quasi der höchste Militär äh der dann im,
die die Hälfte aller Truppen kommandiert, so und ähm ja,
solange es nicht offiziell äh äh ist, muss man das natürlich mit Vorsicht genießen, aber ich habe mir dann eben selber auch äh das Bild.
Angeguckt und verglichen und mein Eindruck, ich bin jetzt kein guter Gesichtserkenner.
Aber ich hatte mir dann so ein paar Punkte ausgeguckt, unter anderem die Ohrform ist immer eine eine gute Möglichkeit
ähm das zu vergleichen und da waren schon äh so ein so ein also oben am,
Ohr äh so eine so eine markante Delle, wie ich fand, die sagen auf beiden Bildern da war zusätzlich ein Muttermal, was allerdings auf dem einen Bild nicht so gut zu sehen war, was man da nur vermuten konnte, aber
insgesamt äh doch ich sage mal selbst für mich als schlechten Gesichtserkenner sah das aus äh wie ein und dieselbe Person und,
wenn sich Tas äh bewahrheitet, das wäre natürlich
äh super krass, nicht nur wegen des Generals, sondern weil man dann davon ausgehen kann, dass sie ähm auch das Hauptquartier möglicherweise überrannt haben, beziehungsweise dann in den Besitz von
Generalstabs äh Informationen äh gekommen äh sind, die.
Ja vielleicht auch für den für den Kriegsverlauf äh äh wichtig sein könnten, aber äh viel wichtiger ist, dass äh sagen
dieser Mann,
ja Befehle und welche Ziele beschossen werden sollten und Listen von verhafteten, verschleppten und Ermordeten so, die Befehle, die aus Moskau äh gekommen sind.
Also es könnte quasi auch helfen äh dann einfach,
die Verantwortungskette für die Kriegsverbrechen ähm so äh zu rekonstruieren und äh ja äh das also das wäre sozusagen dann auch nochmal, wenn das passiert ist, nochmal eine ganz
üble äh Geschichte für die Russen Plus, natürlich eine Blamage äh ohnegleichen.
So. Das wäre quasi wie wenn die Afghanen irgendwie äh oder die Iraker irgendwie generalschwarzkopf und äh weiß ich nicht, die Afghanen sich
General Christel oder so gefangen genommen hätten.
So, jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, was passiert jetzt eigentlich auf russischer.
Seite. Also das das so eine ein weiteres Vorstoßen der Russen derzeit schwierig. Das haben wir ja im Prinzip jetzt schon mal
erwähnt so also es wird jetzt auf jeden Fall nicht nicht einfacher. Sie reden ja auch die ganze Zeit in ihrer.
In ihrer PR davon dass sie jetzt ja nur ein vornehmen das ist schon irgendwie so ein Lachbegriff auf Twitter wo sich alle die Bäuche halten da ist im Prinzip ja nix anderes ist als eine krasse Niederlage und ein Rückzug an vielen Stellen.
Ja, es ist sogar äh nicht mal in weiten Teilen nicht nur ein geordneter Rückzug, sondern eigentlich ja, eine äh panische Flucht oder ein ungeordneter Rückzug.
Und jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage, was.
Was wird jetzt überhaupt äh passieren, ne, weil auch in den Medien äh sprechen sich jetzt schon Leute gegen
Putin aus, es gibt wohl auch diverse.
Ja, so district officials, also so auf zweiter, dritter Ebene, die sich die wohl schon tatsächlich Putin den Rücktritt nahegelegt haben. Da wird dann auch äh allgemein
vermutet, dass demnächst nochmal so die Zahl an Herzanfällen und Fenster stürzen äh ansteigen könnte.
Aber grundsätzlich ist es ja so sagen wir mal jetzt, gehen wir mal von so einem.
Optimistischen Szenario aus. Sagen wir mal die Ukraine stürmt jetzt auch noch den Norden von Luhansk und schafft es dort große Gebiete zurückzugewinnen. Das halte ich jetzt für nicht ausgeschlossen.
Und sie kappen auch äh noch die letzte ähm Eisenbahnverbindung aus dem Norden von Russland in die Ukraine rein, so. Damit ist dann.
Beispiel so eine Stadt wie Luhansk äh tatsächlich auch von der Versorgung.
Abgeschnitten, weil interessanterweise, obwohl Luhansk relativ nah an der russischen Grenze ist, ist dort keine Eisenbahnverbindungen gibt.
Nach Osten, musste ich auch mit großer Überraschung feststellen. Das heißt, die ganze Situation im Donbass ist so volatil,
man schon damit rechnen kann, dass dort äh unter Umständen ein weiterer Rückzug noch erforderlich ist und die Russen sich unter Umständen komplett auf den Süden
konzentrieren um überhaupt noch was zu halten. Ich meine, die heilige Crew ist natürlich da die Krim. Ne, auch wenn natürlich auch schon der der Don Bars und Johansges wäre schon ein ein ein riesiger äh Verlust und würde wahrscheinlich auch schon reichen, um das Ganze
zusammenbrechen zu lassen, aber man weiß ja auch nicht, wie viel Potenzial jetzt noch in diesem System steckt sich gegen die Realität.
Auf zu bringen so.
Wie gesagt, die unmittelbare äh Reaktion war ja dass sie erstmal hastig Verstärkung geschickt haben, die dann aber voll in die Falle gelaufen.
Ist und dann ähm irgendwie außerdem aus 1tausend Kilometern Entfernung ähm irgendwo Großmithals abgeschossen äh haben, noch nicht mal ausm Schwarzen Meer, sondern irgendwo von weit weg so.
Abgesehen davon, dass die Dinger halt super teuer äh sind. Also es waren diese Angriffe da auf diese Kraftwerke dann, ja und das äh sieht schon eher so wie eine hilflose Geste, äh
aus, ja? Die zumal äh natürlich dann.
Auch äh quasi ja möglicherweise dazu führt, dass die Ukrainer dann Ähnliches in äh Russland machen und dann nicht nur.
Nicht nur ähm ja militärische Ziele angreifen irgendwann. Wird man sehen. Aber auf jeden Fall ja ähm.
Hörbare Unruhe im russischen Staatsapparat und in den.
Staatsmedien und das verrückte ist, dass teilweise die.
Einige der Nationalisten irgendwie der Hardcore-Nationalisten äh fast noch am vernünftigsten klingen, ja, von dem, was sie erzählen und irgendwie die Situation mit am realistischsten einschätzen.
Und es ist wohl jetzt auch ein paar Mal in den Medien das verbotene Wort Krieg gefallen.
Was soll jetzt darauf zurückführt, dass sozusagen in der Aufregung äh den äh Moderatoren unterlaufen ist? So.
Und ähm ja also es,
halt dann schon immer schwieriger jetzt gerade das Ganze irgendwie äh zu verharmlosen oder wegzuargumentieren und.
Und natürlich,
klar bei den Propagandisten erstmal ist jetzt eine Schiene wie das sind gar nicht die Ukrainer, die uns da jetzt äh bekämpft haben, sondern es sind halt vom Westen ausgestattete Horden, äh die äh ja.
Äh die da äh ja äh jetzt äh über die äh armen Russen hergefallen sind, die eigentlich nur, ich sage mal, aus humanitären äh äh Gründen äh dort.
Waren gerade und äh.
Stimmt natürlich auch bei den ukrainischen Truppen sind sehr wohl auch internationale Kämpfer, aber die machen natürlich keinen großen Anteil aus.
Nee, nee. So ja, jedenfalls am Anfang, am ersten Tag.
Am zweiten Tag gab's dann auch noch so ein paar Propagandisten, die meinten ja das sei in Wirklichkeit nur eine raffinierte Falle, mit der die Russen die Ukrainer jetzt in die Falle gelockt hätten und wären dann in einer Zangenbewegung irgendwie
sie abschneiden und dann einkesseln und vernichten, schlagen, so das,
Ja ähm das hat sich aber dann jetzt nicht so äh herausgestellt und wie gesagt, jetzt sind's halt die die gemeinen äh Horden äh NATO und USA Horden.
Die da jetzt über die Unschuldigen russischen Soldaten äh hereingebrochen sind.
Eine Sache war ja noch, dass ja jetzt hier äh ähm wohl jetzt auch wirklich weg ist, sagen seine Abschiedszeremonie.
Also der Tschetschenen-Führer, ne.
Der Tschetschenen-Führer genau, der da groß getönt hatte und dann sich irgendwie ähm.
Vor ein paar Tagen auf TikTok Mail und meinte, er hätte jetzt irgendwie genug regiert und wird jetzt mal eine Auszeit nehmen. So, jetzt unklar zu sagen, hat Putin ihn da jetzt äh.
Absolviert oder hat er sich überlegt äh nee ähm ich mache da jetzt nicht mehr mit, das ist mir zu blöd. Ich will da jetzt raus.
Er hat ja auch offene äh äh Putin kritisiert, ne? Sogar, also oder zumindest indirekt, also er hat so
gesagt so ja äh die Leute sollten langsam mal schauen, was da jetzt wirklich äh passiert und er würde jetzt bald mal erzählen, was da wirklich äh äh vor sich geht alles so
merkwürdige Formulierung.
Müssten sie ja dann alle schon äh wissen, obwohl ich auch noch den Eindruck habe, dass so diese selbst ausgelöste Realitätsverweigerung, die allgemein dem Apparat vorhält, ne, also die sich einfach.
Einfach nicht vorstellen können, dass dass sie irgendwas zu verlieren haben. Das.
Einfach gar nicht so an sich heranlassen und dass das natürlich auch ein Problem ist bei der ganzen Planung dieses Krieges.
Ich meine, die Frage ist was gibt's denn für,
Optionen jetzt grade bisschen andiskutiert hatten. Wer äh das Ganze äh Thema Mobilmachung.
Hatten wir halt immer wieder mal äh aber äh.
An der Stelle scheint äh Putin nicht zu sein und es ist auch nach wie vor fraglich, ob es überhaupt.
Ähm dazu kommt, weil erstmal müssen wir natürlich das Narrativ ändern, da müsste man irgendwie aus der speziellen Militäroperation einen Krieg machen.
Und das wäre halt schon ein bisschen peinlich und dann ist aber das Hauptproblem, dass halt.
Der Erfolg nicht garantiert ist, dass es halt eventuell nichts nützen würde, weil äh äh zum einen man davon ausgeht, dass ganz viele Leute, weil das Russland ist, dann versuchen würden sich zu drücken so.
Einfach verschwinden oder was auch immer tun, um möglichst halt nicht gezogen zu werden, Leute bestechen, sodass wir.
Quasi das das eine Problem und dass man dann eventuell auch gar nicht genug Leute hat, die nicht die,
die man noch irgendwo abziehen ähm könnte.
Und äh ja ganze Probleme auch mit Ausbildern und Ausbildung und dann mein wenn ihr jetzt schon es nicht gelungen ist äh die Leute
die jetzt da sind, vernünftig auszurüsten, ist jetzt nicht zu sehen, äh wie
sie jetzt gleichzeitig äh die Ausrüstung, die verlorene, ersetzen, ja, für die Truppen, die sie schon,
haben, die abgenutzt äh wurde oder verschossen wurde und dass sie dann noch jetzt in der Lage sein sollten, quasi.
In größerem Umfang äh dann äh Truppen zu bewaffnen, die sie dann bei einer Mobilmachung äh kriegen. Äh jedenfalls.
Alles nur mit einem Zeithorizont von ein anderthalb Jahren äh so, also ganz schnell wird man da nicht nicht wirklich was ähm verändern und.
Auf der anderen Seite eben dann die die Risiken, so dass das halt für eben Ärger,
im Land äh sorgt und bis hin dann zu so grundsätzlichen Aspekten, dass dann natürlich auch plötzlich dann viele Reservisten aus der russischen Garde und Innenministeriumstruppen,
man entweder dann dahin schicken muss so und sich sozusagen im Inneren auch noch entblößt und die Aufstandsbekämpfung schwächt
und dann natürlich, wenn man ist es auch immer so ein Ding dann in in in Russland äh hast du dann halt
äh ein Haufen voll bewaffneter äh Zwangsrekruten, äh die, wenn sie dann eventuell zu
ja demotiviert sind oder äh sich dann auch gegen das Regime wenden können. Das ist halt dann auch immer so ein so ein äh Risiko so.
Ja ähm auf der anderen Seite gibt's halt in Russland bisher.
Im zivilen Bereich nicht wirklich Versorgungsengpässe, ist wohl alles teurer geworden. Halt interessant, dass wahrscheinlich das iPhone 14 wird halt erst mit ein, zwei Tage später erhältlich sein und zu überhöhten Preisen
aber Apple betreibt und versorgt halt auch noch die Reparaturzentren für Apple Produkte in Russland so.
Aber verkaufen tun sie dort nix mehr.
Nee, verkaufen nicht, aber äh sagen, wenn dein iPhone kaputtgeht oder so, kannst du's dort dir immer noch reparieren lassen.
Und ähm ja und ansonsten, wenn das interessant ist, dass sie wohl.
Vor ein paar Monaten schon also als Reaktion auf die Sanktionen den äh.
Gebietsschutz oder das Verbot von Grau Importen aufgehoben haben.
In Russland irgendwie ein Gesetz äh nachdem halt eben Sachen nur.
Zustimmung des Herstellers importiert werden dürfen.
Also krasser als bei uns noch, weil bei uns sind in dem Sinne Grau Importe nicht wirklich verboten, aber ja und deswegen ähm so man halt dort lebende Russen, na ja, es gibt halt nach wie vor alles
Aber manche Sachen sind halt jetzt super teuer, weil sie halt.
Ja aus anderen Ländern importiert werden müssen halt viel so aus Armenien wohl und Kasachstan und so, da
da holen sie sich halt jetzt hauptsächlich ihre äh ja Konsumprodukte und Konsumelektronik her, aber es gibt eben jetzt keine Preisgarantien.
Mehr oder keine festen Preise und äh dann extreme Preisschwankungen und so und auch ansonsten also Nahrungsmittel, ich meine, die Geschäfte sind sind voll und so und da steht.
Aber natürlich alles so ein bisschen im Widerspruch zu dem Bild, was die äh Ami grade abliefert, so.
Weil ähm das das passt irgendwie beides nicht so richtig zusammen.
Frage ist natürlich auch immer so, was was würde er, also viele fragen sich natürlich so, oh äh jetzt wird Putin aber böse, so.
Was könnte er jetzt noch äh tun, gerade im Hinblick dadrauf, dass unter Umständen auch noch seine eigene Position wackelt und er jetzt dringend irgendwelche Erfolge vorweisen muss?
Welche welche Eskalations äh Potenzial existiert denn überhaupt noch? Und das ist ja auch in der ganzen politischen Diskussion immer so ein so ein Spruch so oh ja nee wir wollen ja hier nicht eskalieren. Wobei ich mich äh schon die ganze Zeit immer wieder frage.
Wie viel Eskalation braucht ihr denn eigentlich noch so? Ich meine, es ist auch alles schon total äh eskaliert. Der hat ein Land überfallen und irgendwie ein Genozid gestartet. Äh da werden,
Ganze Städte in Schutt und Asche äh gelegt, also sehr viel mehr kann man sich von einer Eskalation ja gar nicht versprechen.
Und äh in gewisser Hinsicht macht Russland gerade so nicht den Eindruck oder bisher haben sie nicht so den Eindruck gemacht, dass sie äh irgendeine Eskalation ausgelassen haben. Also es eskaliert ja eigentlich die ganze Zeit schon.
Ja, ja, eigentlich schon eigentlich sind die Russen, man hat das Gefühl schon ziemlich am Ende der Fahnenstange angekommen. Ich meine, wenn sie halt.
Die aus tausend Kilometer Groß-Messals äh verschießen äh müssen, so denn
ja ist das schon ein Zeichen, dass sie nicht viel haben und gut in dem Zusammenhang äh kommt natürlich immer jetzt die atomare Eskalation ähm ins Spiel.
Und ähm wird bei Propagandisten auch immer gefordert, da war so, weiß nicht, eine Frau äh im Fernsehen, die dann meinte, ja äh.
Glauben doch wohl nicht, dass Russland verlieren kann. Ich meine, Russland hat Atomwaffen so. Wir können nicht verlieren.
Ja so und äh so aber äh ja,
Dabei vergessen sie halt, dass halt ja Atomwaffen der USA weder in Vietnam noch in Afghanistan, Irak oder Syrien genützt haben und der Sowjetunion auch nicht in Afghanistan
äh so und ähm ja, der Weg meint irgendwie auch flat Wechsler, so ein russischer, intellektueller
ähm auch ja die Art und Weise, wie man halt eine Atommacht
besiegt, ist halt wirtschaftlich so, indem man einfach äh ja eine Situation herstellt, wo einfach das Führen des Krieges einfach zu teuer wird und.
Ansonsten äh hat mir auch einer der früheren äh Sendungen. Es gibt halt sowas wie eine nukleares Tabu. So der Ersteinsatz von Atomwaffen gegen den Nicht-Atomwaffenstaat äh äh.
Ist halt stark tabuisiert, weil das eben katastrophale Folgen für die nukleare Proliferation hätte, weil dann irgendwie jeder und sein Bruder sich Atomwaffen zulegen äh äh,
wollen, würde, so.
Wie wir das in Nordkorea gesehen haben.
Ja ja so
aber das würde dann eben auch nicht nur quasi jetzt für Nordkorea oder sondern dann würden halt alle Staaten zurecht sagen ey
so
ja das ist quasi ein Verstoß dann auch gegen den Atomwaffensperrvertrag so und äh würden sagen, nee also wenn wenn es wenn es so läuft so, dann
was sollen wir anderes machen als uns Atomwaffen zuzulegen, ja weil sonst sind dann sind wir ja irgendwie Opfer. So und deswegen ja.
Plus, dass eben auch zum Beispiel China und Indien und der Rest der Welt, wenn Russland dort Atomwaffen jetzt einsetzt, äh sich dann auch noch gegen äh Russland stellen äh würden, so. Also dann werden sie
komplett isoliert, äh glaube ich. Deswegen und das das weiß äh äh Putin.
Auch äh so ähm und äh deswegen ist es halt extrem unwahrscheinlich. Klar, ausschließend kann man's nie.
Und natürlich mit jedem Eskalationsschritt, ich sage mal,
an der nuklearen Eskalation auch irgendwo ein Stück näher. Was aber nicht bedeutet, dass man sie deswegen dann zwangsläufig irgendwann äh erreichen muss und ich halte es, wie gesagt, nach wie vor,
für extrem unwahrscheinlich, zumal
in dem Fall dann eben auch definitiv eine militärische Reaktion des äh Westens äh kommen würde, wenn Russland Atomwaffen,
erstmalig einsetzt. Davon äh ja.
Kann man sicher ausgehen.
Kann man ausgehen, wie die.
Mit Atomwaffen wäre.
Wie die ausfallen würde, ist ist unklar, aber äh so ähm ja insofern.
Ja oder die andere Variante ist eben glaube ich die die Putin am ehesten so vorschwebt ist na ja.
Äh einfach durchhalten,
weitermachen, so äh mehr Truppen ausheben, die Produktion ankurbeln und dann äh ja gucken äh Plus natürlich klar äh uns das Gas abdrehen.
Und äh versuchen irgendwie uns davon abzubringen, die Ukraine weiter zu unterstützen, aber ja, dass dieser Plan läuft gerade auch nicht so gut.
So und vielleicht noch jawohl grad beim Gas sind halt zwei.
Worte äh dazu. Also äh je nachdem, wie der Winter verläuft, äh so
wird in Europa das Gas vielleicht im Februar äh oder könnte das Gas im Februar knapp werden. Ähm oder auch nicht.
So und es mangelt halt auch nicht wirklich an Gas, sondern vor allem an billigen Gas und ähm ja,
Insofern also die die Gaserpressung wird halt nicht funktionieren, auch allein schon deswegen, weil ich meine.
Äh das das ist ja kein kein Zustand ja also warum sollte man dann sagen von Russland noch äh.
Irgendwie ja.
Gas nehmen, wenn man erstens sowieso weg will äh davon und sich wieder irgendwie erneut in Abhängigkeit äh begeben.
Also ähm im Prinzip, die Russen können machen, was sie wollen und ich erwarte eigentlich eher, dass sie äh Gaslieferungen wieder aufnehmen oder sogar verstärken irgendwann. Also das halte ich auch für eine
finde mögliche Variante. So, das wir haben Turbine wieder repariert und äh jetzt geht's weiter.
Ja, das haben wir ja schon besprochen. Ist ja auch tatsächlich so, dass der Gaspreis jetzt schon wieder fällt und zwar ziemlich stark.
Und,
Von daher ja also wenn ich Putin wäre hm also langsam gehen einfach da echt die die Optionen aus und.
Weitermachen. Einfach könnte sich eben auch nicht wirklich als nachhaltig oder oder durchführbar äh.
Rausstellen
Und ja, also besteht zumindest eine eine gewisse Chance, dass ähm es vielleicht schneller zu Ende sein könnte als alle erwarten, aber die wahrscheinlichste Variante ist, dass äh noch nicht.
Also letzten Endes das,
letzte Territorium, sagen wir mal es geht äh so weiter äh mit den russischen Niederlagen, das letzte Territorium, was sie dann noch ähm,
Zu verteidigen hätten, ist die Krim.
Das wird so auf jeden Fall das letzte Gebiet sein, weil da ja mal abgesehen jetzt von diesen ein, zwei, drei Angriffen mit.
Oder was es auch immer war, auf die äh einzelnen Standorte äh ja noch kein wirklicher Krieg stattgefunden hat, aber in dem Moment, wo der Süden wieder zurück an die Ukraine fällt, werden die natürlich dann auch nicht Halt machen.
Ist halt das Ding. Also gerade ja jetzt ein ein Vorsto
im äh Süden, wie ich vorhin angedeutet hatte, ja, was alles noch Theorie ist, was passieren kann oder eben auch nicht passieren kann, aber sagen wir mal äh sie wären jetzt in der Lage im
Süden, damit meine ich jetzt nicht äh Herren, sondern jetzt wirklich eher da so äh die Nordküste äh des Asowschen
Meeres, also Maropol und äh Bett Jansk und diese Städte, wenn's ihnen also in irgendeiner Form gelingt, dorthin vorzudringen oder nach Melitopol. Äh und sie
Meer kommen, dann wird natürlich auch die Situation in der Krim äh dünner, ne, weil dann,
können die Ukrainer mit den Heimasraketen dort genauso ähm die Russen in die Bredouille bringen und vor allem halt auch die Kehrbrücke angreifen.
Das ist dann so dann dann kann es eben wirklich sein, dass sie äh auch noch diese letzten Versorgungspunkt platt machen.
Plus die Luftwaffenbasen plus die ganzen Schiffe der Schwarzmeerflotte, die da ja irgendwie dann.
Ähm auch noch äh sind, also ja ich meine.
Sollte jetzt den den Tag nicht vor dem Abend loben und äh jetzt natürlich nicht äh ja äh zu euphorisch.
Werden, aber auf der anderen Seite ja einfach bei nüchterner Betrachtung der Option. Also.
Einzige Variante ist, dass Putin vielleicht, so wie die Ukraine, auch noch irgendwo jetzt Reserven hat oder locker macht oder.
Gut äh äh und.
Müsste es ja irgendwo auch noch Reserven geben, also komplett die Landesverteidigung wird da ja nicht entblößt haben.
Und äh das wäre dann auch noch eine Variante, dass er sagt, na ja gut, die NATO wird nicht kommen, ich ziehe jetzt halt alles, was sonst noch so an den Grenzen stationiert
ist, äh schicke ich da jetzt in den in den Kampf ähm aber ja,
Das äh aber ansonsten ja wird's wird's tatsächlich immer enger und und.
Dünner und hm ich möchte nicht in seiner Haut äh sein.
Andere Variante wäre noch, dass er jetzt dann ganz schnell erklärt, okay äh.
Ob Militäroperation ist abgeschlossen. Ähm.
Sind alle besiegt.
Wir haben's genau, aber wir haben, wir haben immer gesagt, na ja, angeblich könne Putin irgendwie den Leuten halt mithilfe der Propaganda alles
einreden, aber hm ganz so funktioniert's dann natürlich auch nicht. So es gibt dann eben Grenzen, die man dann die Realität tatsächlich strecken.
Kann, ähm zumal das eben auch dann ganz viele Leute im Apparat äh gibt, die dann äh ja,
selber praktische Probleme äh haben oder bekommen.
Und was jetzt halt auch in der Bevölkerung äh.
Ja für etwas Überraschung gesorgt hat, war, dass die Russen jetzt keine Touristenvisa mehr bekommen.
Von der EU.
Nur noch irgendwie humanitäre äh Einreisen äh so wenn jemand wenn Verwandter gestorben äh ist und Journalisten äh kriegen wohl noch Visa äh,
aber das war's dann. Also Touristen in der ganzen EU nicht mehr.
Damit kommen wir im Prinzip jetzt mal so äh zu zu der Perspektive von uns, ne, also der westlichen.
Mal diese Ukraine stark unterstützt, vor allem natürlich die USA und Großbritannien.
Ähm dann sage ich auch nur äh richtig so, weil habt ihr ja mal unterschrieben irgendwie ne so Budapässeabkommen und so weiter. Ihr habt ja auch eine Garantie abgegeben. Insofern kann man sagen, sind sie dem auch nachgekommen?
Und durch diese Offensive jetzt in äh Rakif ändert sich ja jetzt auch der Ton.
Nämlich vorher hatten wir hier immer so Debatten mit Russland kann ja nicht verlieren und so weiter, da vielleicht,
Irgendwann es wurde immer gesagt, sie sie dürften nicht gewinnen, aber man ist halt immer davon ausgegangen, dass sie in irgendeiner Form die Ukraine platt machen können, nicht. Wir erinnern uns am Anfang,
des Krieges äh hieß es ja nach zwei Tagen ist Kiew gefallen und dann war's das und dann ist der Selinski ist dann irgendwie äh weg und die Amerikaner haben schon mal ein Flugzeug angeboten und dann kam's ja zu diesem.
Großartigen Video, was wahrscheinlich in die Geschichte eingehen wird, wo er damit seinen äh Ministerpräsidenten und äh Verteidigungsminister und so weiter äh steht in äh Kiew vor seinem Regierungsgebäude und sagt, Leute.
Keiner irgendwo hin. Wir werden jetzt hier bleiben. Wir werden jetzt die Ukraine verteidigen und äh wir geben ihnen Saures
Alle haben so ein bisschen geschwitzt und sie haben Kragen gezogen, äh ob denn das jetzt in irgendeiner Form passieren kann und was wir halt jetzt gesehen haben ist,
Ja, sie können das und äh es gab Leute, die hatten da nie einen Zweifel dran und es gibt Leute, die äh haben halt bis.
Kurzem noch daran gezweifelt, aber dass diese Zweifel werden gerade im,
Hochgeschwindigkeit ausgeräumt, weil was willst du jetzt bitte noch in dieser Diskussion erreichen? Es ist vollkommen klar, wenn die Ukraine mit ausreichend Waffen versorgt wird.
Dann sind sie in der Lage, die Russen zu vertreiben und hätten wir das schon mehr getan, als wir's bisher,
haben, damit wir meine ich jetzt der ganze Westen, äh dann sähe die Situation vielleicht äh jetzt auch schon ganz anders aus. Nichtsdestotrotz der Zeitpunkt scheint nun,
kommen zu sein und die Debatten gehen los, ne? Also äh
in jedem Land wieder ein bisschen äh bisschen anders, äh aber auch diese ganze Visa-Geschichte, die ja von Finnland angestoßen wurde
Sind halt auch alles solche Debatten, wo man sich dann eben positionieren muss, ne? Also es gab ja einen
Privileg für die Russen, also eine Sonderregelung, dass es sozusagen schneller an äh Visa kam. Du hast es jetzt Touristenvisor genannt, ich weiß nicht, ob's offiziell so hieß, glaube ich nicht.
Es gab ein sogenanntes beschleunigtes Visumsverfahren, so.
Das ist jetzt eingestellt worden. Das heißt, sie müssen jetzt irgendwie äh einen Monat warten oder länger und äh kosse auch mehr et cetera.
Nee, nicht nur, es ist sozusagen so sozusagen es gibt keine Visa. Also vorher war's noch so, dass so halt äh mit Nachweis, dass du
ähm ja dort auch Vermögen und Familie hast und nicht vorhast zu immigrieren, dann musst du halt beim Visum auch die entsprechenden Unterlagen beibringen und so und dann äh ja ging das schon, aber jetzt ist
egal. Das Einzige, was jetzt noch geht, ist irgendwie, keine Ahnung, meine Großmutter ist äh gestorben oder so und.
Dazu muss man aber auch sagen, dass erstens Russland selbst wohl auch
teilweise vielen Leuten sogar aus humanitären Gründen, die irgendwie da bei einer Beerdigung teilnehmen wollten, Visa verweigert, hat in den schon seit Monaten, insofern kann man sagen, ist das fast nur reziprok
und ähm gerade in manchen Ländern, also was was eben so ein Argument war, äh womit,
dann äh halt auch die anderen EU-Länder, die erstmal nicht so begeistert waren von der Idee, keine Russen mehr reinzulassen war.
Dass es eben Konflikte gab, dass russische Touristen dann äh Ukrainer, die sich geflüchtet haben, wohl angegriffen haben oder beschimpft haben. Äh so
und ähm
Das wollte man sich halt einfach nicht länger bieten lassen plus natürlich so Erwägungen mit, keine Ahnung, dass dann auch noch Saboteure und Spione in größerer Zahl ins Land kommen.
Die haben dann glaube ich überzeugt, dass man sagt, okay, also bis auf Weiteres äh wie gesagt nur Journalisten und äh,
nur zur Beerdigung. So ungefähr. Ähm es ist jetzt die die Situation und.
Was halt aber auch noch krass ist, dass sogar Montenegro jetzt.
Visa von Russen haben will. Bei Montenegro eigentlich eher so Russland, freundliches Land, viele Russen haben sich da auch Ferienwohnungen und Villen.
Gekauft und die zeigen den Russen aber jetzt auch gerade den Finger, also die brauchen jetzt sogar für Monte Negro einen einen Visum.
Neuerdings. Also ähm ja und wie gesagt, bei vielen Russen.
Das können die nicht machen. Wir bringen doch denen schließlich Geld und wenn wir vorher was, das werden die nicht machen und äh gehen wohl vielen Russen grade, so verstehen die Welt nicht mehr
was denn irgendwie los ist. Nicht alle, manche verstehen's halt sehr gut am Verständnis für die Maßnahmen, so dass eben keine pöbelnden Touristen äh äh ins Land lassen willst, die irgendwie ukrainische Flüchtlinge anmachen.
So hm ja.
Ja ich hoffe ja, dass ich die deutsche äh Position hier noch ähm verbessert. Ich weiß nicht ähm wie du da die Zeichen.
Mittlerweile wird viel Druck auf die SPD ausgeübt, die ja ein bisschen so die Hauptspassbremse zu sein äh scheint,
ne, während sich die Grünen ja eigentlich relativ klar positioniert haben und glaube auch, die CDU und auch die FDP, eigentlich die SPD, so die Einzigen, die da noch so ein bisschen am.
Bremsen sind, ne.
Ja. Also ich meine erstmal wenn man ja festhalten, dass jetzt äh quasi bestimmte Kritik.
Die geäußert wurde bisher an mehr Waffenlieferungen
einfach jetzt entkräftet ist, also bestimmte Argumente. Also erstmal irgendwie na ja, wenn wir den Ukrainern die Waffen schicken, dann fallen die ja sowieso nur in die Hände der Russen und
äh die wissen sowieso nicht, wie sie damit kämpfen sollen, mit unseren tollen Hightech Waffen, so dann Ukrainer jetzt ganz klar gezeigt, dass sie
alles, was Sie bisher bekommen haben, äh hervorragend
einsetzen äh können und eben auch nicht in großer Zahl verlieren, sondern damit äh ja gut umgehen mit unseren Waffen, ja.
Eher noch plus machen, ne? Also sie haben jetzt mehr Waffen als vorher.
Ja plus sich sozusagen mit Hilfe unserer Waffen noch mehr Waffen von den Russen jetzt geholt haben. So also der ja genau, also der Punkt.
Sagen äh also dieser Kritikpunkt äh ja kann man kann man sagen.
Es nicht. Die Ukrainer äh ja,
gut mit unseren Waffen um. So kann man sagen. Ähm ja und dann hat's natürlich jetzt eben auch die Option eröffnet beziehungsweise das das
Argument, na ja, äh unsere Waffenlieferungen verlängern ja nur den Krieg,
in äh na ja und mehr Waffenlieferungen können den Krieg vielleicht auch jetzt schneller äh zum Ende bringen, so also zumindest er hat das jetzt in den in den Köpfen
in vielen Köpfen, wo es noch nicht drin war, diese Option eröffnet, ja, also oder mit anderen Worten ist es jetzt,
kein gutes Argument, dass Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine äh den Krieg verlängern. Ja, das kann man also auch wegpacken so und.
Die Frage ist, was.
Denn irgendwie jetzt noch äh an Argumenten in Deutschland übrig, dass die Russen uns das Gas abdrehen könnten. Ich meine ja äh.
Ja
Ist ist halt auch schon passiert.
Auch nicht, wie die Beziehung noch noch schlechter werden soll nach äh nach Russland. Also ich meine, was was gibt's denn jetzt überhaupt noch zu verlieren? Eigentlich gar nix.
Ja, na ja, äh gut, es gibt immer schon noch, also es im Krieg gibt's halt schon noch unschöne Eskalations äh Stufen.
Aber also.
Das Ganze kann dann natürlich auch noch, also Putin könnte halt eskalieren und weitere Länder mit reinbringen. Andererseits wär's natürlich jetzt auch eine wunderbare Gelegenheit, hm ich meine
Russland gibt's ja auch nun genug Spannungen und genug Nachbarländer oder Abtrünnige Republiken und äh ja äh wenn man
da jetzt dann für Ärger sorgt oder äh plötzlich ich sage mal äh ja dort eben verschiedene Gegenden,
Länder, Völker, Nachbarn, die sowieso noch ein Beef haben mit mit Russland, wär's natürlich jetzt auch eine gute Gelegenheit äh für Unruhe äh,
zu sagen und ähm ja sich sich abzusetzen, wird man sehen äh auf jeden Fall ist
na ja die Möglichkeit eines Zusammenbruchs Russlands, auch wenn der im Moment nicht wahrscheinlich ist so äh zumindest.
Nicht mehr ausgeschlossen, ja ähm und da gibt's jetzt auch schon Warner, die meinten, ja, der Westen war auf den Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion überhaupt nicht vorbereitet
und wir sollten zumindest jetzt mal gucken, äh zumindest halt ja diese Option erwägen, okay, was was können wir denn, was was tun wir denn?
Wenn das passieren sollte, wenn plötzlich ja irgendjemand Putin
umbringt und äh oder äh ja einen einen einen Putsch passiert und plötzlich weiß ich nicht 15 Regionen irgendwie ihren Austritt aus der Russischen Föderation
äh erklären und äh ja so das kann,
auch, ich meine damals Sowjetunion, das ist auch plötzlich innerhalb von zwei oder drei Tagen, ja, ist das ist das passiert.
Also ich sehe nicht, dass Russland jetzt sich äh schon in dieser Situation befindet, aber ja, das kann überraschend und schnell.
Äh sich sich auch wenden oder drehen.
Diese ganzen Abgrenzungen, Tendenzen, das ist ja nix Neues. So was gibt es ja in Russland. Nur bisher ist der Apparat halt einfach auch Kraft seiner Armee äh und Sicherheitssystems eben auch entsprechend,
zusammengehalten worden, ne, aber na gut, es ist nicht unbedingt absehbar, wie diese super armen Gebiete äh sich alleine überhaupt behaupten wollen
Aber gibt ja auch ganz andere äh Regionen eher im Westen Russlands, die sich das vielleicht dann auch noch mal äh anders überlegen. Und es könnte natürlich auch noch Implikationen haben für so Gebiete wie Georgien.
Wo Russland ja auch noch äh Gebiete besetzt oder Transnistrien
also wirklich der russische Kriegsapparat jetzt zusammenbricht und dann eben auch noch diese Ordnung und quasi damit dann auch noch die Putindoktrin, also sozusagen das aktuelle Denken Russlands
sich erstmal neu ausrichtet, dass dann eben die auch alle ähm sozusagen sich umorientieren oder ja,
irgendwas Unüberlegtes tun.
Genau bis hin zu Kaliningrad, was sowieso in der EU besser aufgehoben wäre. Ähm.
Liniengrad, meinst du wirklich? Was in der EU besser aufgehoben wäre? Inwiefer.
Mhm. Na ja, äh na ja, da gibt's ja schon eine schon eine Debatte. Also das.
Das ist ich meine, das ist ein riesiger Militärhafen äh der Russen, also das werden sie auf gar keinen Fall hergeben.
Nein, nein, nicht, nicht, nicht hergeben, aber äh ja.
Kaliningrad unabhängig macht.
Solche Tendenzen.
Also jetzt äh also es gab zumindest welche ähm so ähm.
Wo man gesagt hat, na ja, ich meine, die ja
Das ist eine Exklave so und äh die Nachbarländer sind mittlerweile alle, denen geht's allen viel besser und äh ja so richtig gut entwickeln tut sich das da auch nicht, aber okay.
Ist jetzt ja vielleicht.
Ein bisschen zu.
Bisschen viel der ja aber auf jeden Fall ähm ist es zumindest.
Sag mal, kann man dem im Moment eine von eine Wahrscheinlichkeit größer null ein äh räumen,
deutlich größer als null, dass es plötzlich äh zu einem Zusammenbruch von Russland kommt.
Das ist jetzt ja ich persönlich würde das irgendwie auf fünf, zehn, 15 Prozent oder so schätzen die Wahrscheinlichkeit, aber.
Höher als noch vor einem Monat.
Gut Pavel, ich denke an dieser Stelle können wir's auch erstmal äh belassen. Ich habe so das Gefühl, wir werden in relativ,
kurzen Zeitraum im Vergleich zu den Pausen, die wir zuletzt gemacht haben, hier nochmal das Geschehen besprechen, weil hier ist jetzt einfach eine ganze Menge Musik drin und ähm ja, ich
wir werden von den offensiven der Ukraine in den nächsten Tagen noch eine Menge hören und dann werden wir das äh auch nochmal covern.
Ja so.
Dieser Stelle mal den den Sack zu für diese Sendung und hoffen, dass wir euch einen hilfreichen Überblick über die Geschehnisse äh gegeben haben. Ja und wollen das natürlich auch weiterhin noch tun.
Und ja, drücken wir weiter mal den Ukrainern die Daumen und äh.
Ja hoffen, dass in Russland irgendwie.
Jetzt mal Leute zur Vernunft kommen und äh das Richtige tun, nehme ich einfach morgen mit dem Krieg aufzuhören, dann ist ja nämlich vorbei.
Alles klar, bis bald. Tschüss.
Okay.